bon pour l'instant va on va parler un
petit peu d'actualité avec un scoop
un flash du professeur ruquier et puis
tout de suite après on va parler
gastronomie avec françois roboth tout de
suite le professeur ou qui la scène se
passe dans un hôpital psychiatrique du
fin fond de l'angleterre
je fuis la cousine de la reine
d'angleterre je suis la cuisine de la
reine d'angleterre
cris une malade et moi je suis le petit
frère de napoléon 1er répondent
infirmiers à yop à la douche comme tout
le monde
cette histoire est presque vrai si on en
croit le scandale révélé par un journal
britannique
la famille royale auraient caché pendant
dix ans une cousine de la reine en la
faisant passer pour morte
voilà qui ne fait plus l'ombre d'un
doute
les anglais ont un sens taux commun du
droit d'asile
mais ce n'est pas le cas d'adrienne bien
un qui est